fire some rockets at these
cars massive piles of stuff look at that
boom
Oh fire some rockets at the ground when
I flip
over what was that
noise hey what's up welcome to ROM
encounter how you doing the weekly live
streaming show where me that Irish guy
from that gang website plays a random
video game on the internet today's
random video game is absolutely
brilliant I've been playing this for
about two weeks uh bug bear are a studio
which I love they are based in Finland
they made the flat out series which I've
played I believe every single one of all
the PC ones and the 360 game which I
believe was called flat out Ultimate
Carnage they basically are a bunch of
guys who make destruction Derby type
games lots of of destructibility uh with
races with destruction Derby mini games
uh the flat series had a bunch of really
crazy stuff like I think myself and Seb
actually might have done a random
encounter a while ago like you know
bowling where you'd shoot you hit a
button and you'd shoot the driver out of
the car and they hit the pins and stuff
um but their latest car game called Next
Car Game is in Alpha at the moment on
Steam and you can get access to it and
if you do you get access to their Alpha
which they're updating quite fre L they
just only pushed an update about two
days ago you also get access to this
this is their technology sneak peek
version 2.0 so this is basically a tech
demo uh we're going to play this first
and then after uh I've kind of shown off
a bit of this we're going to get into uh
the the game proper I guess uh I don't
even know what to say about this so I'm
just going to just going to jump
in here we go NextCar
game.com so you basically just spawn in
here with a bunch of other cars smash
each other
up bunch of activities big robot spider
obviously uh but there's a lot more
weird stuff in here that we'll kind of
we'll get to the the Crux of the flat
experience is physics and what they've
done in this one is they've they've sort
of expanded on physics in terms of how
much stuff can have physics and also in
terms of the damage
which is kind of comically stupid so my
car here is getting uh having a bad
day all right now I want to get out of
here come on get me out of here but as
you can see it's still operating
completely fine it's uh well I won't say
completely fine okay we're nearly there
it's the last last machine come on come
on
oh reverse no it's not looking too hot
so their brand of physics is
like it's not super realistic obviously
my my driver's still in there the engine
is totally like gone essentially it's
still running but they're kind of in the
uh
sure but they make fun driving games the
flatted series was really fun I would
say it was quite frustrating when you
would crash and everyone would a
overtake you and in this one they've
certainly fixed that but give you an
idea look at that perfect circle look at
that may not to be proud just repair
everything yeah look this game got hot
physics like look bam all that physics
happening phys I'm going to reverse into
that
physics
H look some posi of stuff
everywhere this is these aren't barrels
these are like concrete I guess mess up
your car pretty
good here we got some tires tire
wall that I'm going to drive
through I'm going to see if I can drive
through all
those don't worry we're going to have
rockets and black holes pretty soon you
think this is crazy here we
go
firewall
yep got you look all that
amazing see this physics over here bam
concrete blocks cardboard boxes
everything look a building eat
it
prefabs I'm stuck
now oh now I'm definitely
stuck I got some of the mini games right
in here as
well like for instance this ridiculous
roller coaster type
ordeal uh I'm going to see if I can get
around this I I've never tried this one
so I la the patience to usually oh Jesus
Christ like that you can you can
your car pretty good with like a real
slow crash as well
uh up the
ramp here we
go a
no repair
reset I'll try that
again
physics can be
cruel this area sadly is no um has no
co-option anig or or any scoring or
anything this is very much just a tech
demo a pre-order exclusive as it says up
in the top left of the screen all the
time H so the next car game thing
apparently they were just like that was
a working title that they were telling
people we are working on something new
and they released that trailer which you
might have seen I think it was about a
year ago now um
yeah I guess that's what happens when
your working title becomes known in the
public is that then that's all people
start referring to your game as so let's
just call Next Car Game and like I kind
of think it's maybe the best name ever
for a car game because all you ever get
with car games is some sort of variation
on a automotive Trope be it like Grid
or dirt or burnout Need for Speed
like they're all just
jaded car terms Jesus don't
crash all
right yeah why not next car game instead
of wipe out it's not really a car game
speed keep the speed there we go just
bits of my car falling off like pieces
of wet cake all
right the end did I win oh
so close
can I reset up there no all right
whatever whatever there's loads of other
stuff to do like for instance this weird
ramp look at that hole I got to try that
hole later
well
go Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam
Bam
physics hold them physics Jesus
Christ looks pretty up but seems
to be
that side's not so bad but then you're
like yeah it's not looking too looking
too
healthy loop the loop at
it LO
dour check out that the hammer beast and
oh look at these
things I manag to get past all of them
and end flipping
me oh God damn it
no ah
do it yeah so not looking too hot for
Miss drive here oh is that like a Peno
machine or something Jesus all right
here we go let's see how many we can
these we can get
through one two three
oh supension suspensions pretty good in
this thing look at this
nonsense
had a front front wheels are doing just
if this was a front-wheel drive car we'd
be completely fine right now all
right doesn't just repair the car as
well when you do that resets all the
um all of the
various puzzles in this world let's try
this jumping mini game
thing don't want to fall off the end
like I did last
time I love how everything destructible
is just
blue like red crates red Barrel syndrome
here we go what distance can we get oh
yeah whatever then at the end you've got
giant robot spider thing for
some
reason Jesus what he did it again
he's look back on my wheels again that
was weird I've never seen that before
hit me hit
me I think he got launched into the sky
that time there you go there you
go I you just love that somebody spent
like a weekend making that
spider in like Finland some Finnish dude
that was his week just making that thing
yeah we'll stick it in the pre-order
bonus don't
worry
oh my
God yeah looks
great I have literally
spent I I've spent more time playing
this Tech demo than I have the actual
beta which is great by the way which I
absolutely love but I've just spent
hours just about in here for the
past two weeks here we go look at this
thing look yeah right cat didn't
make it who cares like great thing about
the flat series is there are a bunch of
driving games where a lot of the time
you don't really care if you even win
like we're going to do a figure of eight
destruction Derby later with like 27
cars and if you finish the race you
win did that thing
get up this car
is they just
like there's like no Rhyme or Reason to
what they put in here like some of this
stuff is clearly for like testing out
various physics features sure then they
just put in like this engine
like what part of the car game is going
to be like they are they testing
here no
denied my car is going to be pretty
up by the end of this I think oh
my
God
what
okay
looks like the car is now just like one
piece of assembly and that's either one
wheel or it's like four wheels crushed
together I really can't
tell man that's pretty
good what what beta
beta still haven't gotten to the rocket
of the black holes don't worry it's
coming what's
this oh man no no not one of these
things
whoa oh God oh God damn it no
no that was so
close the edges of this thing are
deceptively oh oh I think I'm
totally here no no no no God damn
it God
oh sure
yep oh it's like watching one of those
drink driving
commercials actually it's nothing like
that look at that it's okay
I'll repair my car that's better now to
get out of
here all right let's get out of it yeah
it's fine now now we can do it oh this
one's way harder look at this
one this is that the same one oh it's
the same one all right I think there is
a harder
one may be drunk but I think this one
over here is
go we
go oh yeah this one looks way harder in
fact I can SK I I got halfway in this
one before and you basically just you
skip the best way to do it is to skip
this bit and just go down here yep
nailed
it h like I love how they put all these
things in there and they were like
there's too much space in between them
so let's put these triangles in so
there's no way your car can ever rest
easy until it's been like pulverized
into a tiny little four wheeled Jesus
look at
this like what
even not even a car
anymore like and this is like I have
this running on my PC at home which is
not by any means like a a beast like
it's it's pretty good it can run
infinite on bios infinite on on on kind
of everything best I'd say close to it
but like it never has any problems I've
never seen a chug sometimes it the
racing game itself does a bit but like
this physics stuff oh Jesus it doesn't
at all really all right I think it's bad
time we cracked out the the heavy
armaments you hit V on the keyboard you
might see a little Crosshair up here see
it there it's pretty good I can set the
power between one and 10 but the power
for what you ask oh
no things you can launch are numerous
and stupid number one cardboard
boxes so you can set them at like just
one here and you just kind of flop one
out in front of
you got stick a bunch of them look at
physics look about physics you can turn
it up crank it up a bit up to 10 Just
Launch the look at that yeah bam
get out of my way
boxes not just carbo boxes though throw
him with the spider it's also concrete
blocks let's find a car and own him with
some yeah here batter up batter
up look at all that physics
happening that one almost hit me in the
face look at this guy don't worry buddy
I'll flip you back over all right okay
so sometimes this happens sometimes if
there is like so much physics happening
and they crank back on the physics just
for a little bit to stop the game from
crashing or
whatever all right you know what
actually I'm going to do no I'm going to
stay reset
everything fire these look at that is
that a car is that a car hit him on the
volley Bam Bam
Bam Bam Bam Bam Bam blow the crap out of
these cars look concrete block again but
that's not all there is there's also
massive
balls check out my massive balls look at
that bam
bam look at that guy did you see I was
throwing massive
balls just look at this just fired them
off this freaking ramp like loads of
them can't believe that jerk hit me
doesn't you know I've got massive
balls here where's he going where's he
going
H you end up being just like this crazy
like mad physics Hunter just hunting
down all these cars and nailing
them with look at this thing look
where's he going straight into a wall
idiot
uhuh devastating look at that guy look
at his buddy his buddy went to help him
nope
that it's ridiculous why you want to go
in the Pinko
machine look at this bam bam bam bam bam
bam bam
physics
physics okay now we got a bit of slow
down look at
that it starts yeah it's like freaking
out so it stops stops it a bit you
repair them all bam back to normal all
right Pinko
machine
yank
we better take the ramp
up look at that carboard box I put there
earlier
oh
right this a Pachinko machine I guess of
sorts that's pegle a pegle machine to
anyone under the age of
or who hasn't seen Nicholas Cage
commercials or been to Japan all right I
bet I'm supposed to go this
way go let throw some balls down
there oh I totally missed it God damn
it reset
car uh yeah but apart from the mass of
balls we've also got
Rockets Rockets pretty
good fire some rockets at these
cars massive piles of stuff look at that
boom
Oh fire some rockets at the ground and
like flip
over oh yeah this is the physics Cannon
I forgot to show you
this called the physics
Cannon
boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom all
right I love the rocket cuz you can just
fire it at this thing bam look at that
home
dick buildings it's like an action movie
at this
stage but I saved the best for last
Rockets are pretty cool they make things
explode who doesn't like things
exploding look at that
boom stuff exploding is great it's only
seconded sorry it's seconded only by one
thing and that is making things implode
which is why they give you this black
hole machine she going to throw black
holes and stuff I know what thinking how
could that possibly be
better this is
how
now imagine that with a bunch of cars
you don't have to imagine it we're going
to do it right
now oh I up we
car restart we'll do it
again yeah that's right black hole cars
eat
it
look at this this is the future of car
games yeah yeah take that
processor all right I think they've had
enough let's see how they're
doing oh Jesus look at that
guy all right so most of these cars are
now
just bits of tires I
guess
pretty bad that guy look at that
guy at that one there the AI does not
know what the goddamn hell is
happening bunch of them have respawned
over near spider you think the spider's
going to save you
nope physics on cars is fun but physics
on
the oh here we go look at this think
you're getting away from me I got black
holes son black hole son Bon come that's
what that song was
about look at this boom sucks them all
over there
bam
physics at that
boom just yep yep it never gets
old honestly I've played this game for
probably about 6 hours this never gets
old
sometimes I go home and I just with
physics for a while oh God damn
it look at this just physics everything
just physics
a keep doing it everyone come come and
play with
me what's happening anymore look at this
is going
on somebody asks you what video games
are you just just send him
this here yeah went up yeah all your
wooden houses boom boom boom boom
boom this
awfulness people lived in tornadoes are
having post-traumatic stress
over this look at this bam bam bam
bam
bam Next Car
Game wonder how many pre-orders have
gone in since we started doing this
reset car look at that what's even
happening with this
anymore I'm not touching it look I'm
reset car and it just instantly just
goes on its nose
like quivering
wreck reset the car and it's on its
nose action movie look
woo crushed by a bunch of prefabs
or black holes it's the thing about this
stuff is it can never get old
like
is how many times have you played like
the first max pain you just jumping
around for absolutely no reason you're
were like it' probably be easier just to
walk into this room and just shoot these
guys but no I'm going to jump across
everywhere or like if youve ever played
strangle holdes that fantastic John wo
Xbox 360 thing they like sequel to
hardboiled like just slowing down time
and jumping on handrails and being dumb
like there's just something so
satisfying about this nonsense look at
this play some basketball I'm going for
the seven
pointer didn't know it changed the
camera come
on oh Dar
goofed I think I could change the camera
as
well oh I changed the camera so much it
disappeared yeah this is going to be way
easier if I use this
camera
nope
nope we all know where this is
going disable Ai No Way enable
that any more of these more uh mini
games we
missed like we got all of them that one
there ain't that good just a
ramp fighter here knows what's up oh
look at that one yeah all right let me
see how high I can get on that
one going to try I'm going to go to the
edge of the map just try and book it the
whole way over
here map does end if you if you get to
the edge this guy's going to go over the
edge I'm going to help him I'm going to
help you get over the
edge over the
edge he's doing a really good job at
dodging all these concrete
blocks not for long
though
oh where's he
going he drive straight into this
contraption uhoh
Jesus
Christ C for CA full of balls
explosions next car
game that's only half of this that's
only half of the fun
here that's just the stupid physics beta
thing they released the best has yet to
come is the actual
thing total played seven
hours I've probably had more time with
this beta than I have with any other
Early Access thing you kind of need to
turn in some of this stuff because
the because the the amount of a like the
cars I guess the AI is probably like
doing a lot more processing power
because it's actually trying to drive
around a circuit and not just crash into
houses made of
blue
tires but it's slippery red in fact you
know what maybe this is the perfect time
to go to a
break not doing braks no break great
let's keep going
there all right so they've added a bunch
of muscle cars in the latest one we also
have this hot little hot European hot
hatch look at that
guy I'm gonna go for American Muscle
like car like like boy friend I H so
what we got here destruction Derby in a
stadium sure conru Derby in a smaller
Stadium construction Derby in a mud pit
a race in a figure of eight this one
might as well be called destruction
Derby because it is ridiculous I'm going
to do this
one um the weather stuff is the moment
is basically just how's how everything
looks it's not there's no like rain or
anything or stuff like that I'm going to
leave all the assists on for now there
is a bunch of other race on gravel and
stuff we we'll do that in a bit but the
figure of eight stuff is just
magnificent so
let's I have done this one figure of
eight do you remember destruction Derby
where you do that figure of eight race
just all the time and when you'd cross
the middle track and you'd get like
completely sideswiped by somebody it was
just
hilarious like that is basically what
they're trying to distill here except
instead of there only being like eight
other cars or or 7 other cars it's like
20 something look at this
stupidity of this if you actually make
it around the thing three times you're
doing pretty
good oh yeah oh we're doing all right
here actually wow open the third okay
eat that sons of
do they old use another car as
a way to
turn oh all right so we're okay now but
the minute like I feel like the next
time I cross that middle area is where
we're going to start meeting all the
back
markers oh this is probably the luckiest
race I've ever had
oh oh just dudes everywhere
now first is it really
wow it is where it all goes
wrong
w i going to win this is the first time
I've ever
won hell's yeah all
right I'm personally happy about that
obviously I wasn't very entertaining so
we'll do it again I'm not going to not
try this time I'm going to try the exact
same amount I tried last
time I think I started in a really good
position it randomly assigns you where
you are
yeah that's more like
it so the concrete deforms and gets
thrown out onto the track as
well and my car can't really turn left
anymore very well which is a problem for
half of the circuit I guess
Jesus
so many cars and pieces of debris
around and so look
at Jesus there's a lot of cars just out
of this one in front of
my oh turn
turn look at the front of that car in
front look at the car with the red
stripes on it the front of the car is
like just gone oh here we go there he is
right there look at
him so one of the coolest things about
this as well is that they have a really
incredible replay system
um it's like if you had a list of stuff
that you wanted one of these types of
games to have uh they've just got it um
you can also slow down like an
incredible amount so if we let this play
out like this is in three speed
go like it records absolutely
everything and you can do this in free
cam you can like you know stick it to
another car or do whatever look like
even the freakin smoke
effects straight up like speed that
nonsense up
that was a pretty good
crash
Jesus slow down a
bit yeah look at this crash down
here this guy just got sideswiped bit of
concrete just came off his car look at
this and if you want then you can you
can do like all the lens of flex you
want as well so like you get the get
that sexy focal point and that bit of
concrete
there's a lot
of look at this
yeah zoom in and like I don't know
this is
pretty so whenever you've done crashes
and you see like that you want to know
what happened to that one guy that you
sideswiped because he kind of looked
like he was losing his uh his his um
grip like I've gone back and like gone
through the replay system and seen what
happened like there was one guy I
crashed into and he he was in first I
was hunting him for two laps and when I
tapped him he looked like he'd recovered
it and in the replay I looked and he had
just gone wide out the track and went
straight into a tree and was out
of the race we never actually
finished here we
go gets hit again look boom this dude
has just got like half his left taken
away from him cuz now he has to drive
around again
like if if there if there is such a
thing as physics porn
then this game is the red tube of that
look at
that this is why I've been playing this
game so much it's like there's such an
onus on Modern games in like the
completion tree and like the
mission structure look at this
like the ways in which you try and like
keep the gamer playing by like giving
them extra missions and making sure
there's like an unlock system and all
that
like just have like really solid
gameplay people will come back and do
the same thing over and over and over
again I guess that's what like most
multi the best multiplayer Shooters are
or like DOTA for instance like car games
generally they've just turned into this
like
unlock parade of whereas this
is just just like I've played this same
race I cannot tell you how many
times and I'm going to Play It
Again me out of
here yeah let's do it again why not why
the
not this time I'm going to go to the
back and then try and get to the
front all right sorry guys sorry here we
go watch the Carnage unfold in front of
us
yeah yeah get out of my way
who
B chunks of concrete flying up like even
the smoke and everything is just
so
gnarly there we go we're in the we're in
the mix now we're in the
soup the physic
soup
I'm playing this on a controller by the
way and it
is super fun uh no sadly if anyone's
wondering that you can't use any of the
weapons in this uh in this this area of
the
game who knows though these guys are
pretty crazy I wouldn't be surprised if
they just put them
in
oh yep Push Me Over The
Line all right let's check out some of
the other stuff they got on
here man I love this game so
much it's not just that level as well
like the actual races themselves in this
are so much better than they were in
flat
out they have done a way better job of
making sure that you
are like not just getting really pissed
off when you crash because that was
happening a lot they got variance as
well you can do them in Reverse they
got they got variance on some of them as
well track under
construction H all right I'm going to do
sand pit I think this is one of the new
ones I think this one isn't finished as
well actually I think I might be still
building this one so see what happens
also isn't that the best loading screen
you've ever seen that dude just
nailed that
tree like the center of his car is
hitting the center mass of that
tree like a yes
strike all right this looks
promising what I love about these tracks
is that that you'll come around a corner
and somebody would have hit the tire
wall and there will just be tires and
bouncing everywhere and you
are trying desperately to dodge
them oh yeah look it's also got signs
for Miss
bollock eat it eat it eat the tire wall
you son of a
yeah oh
I don't even care don't even care
don't even care I'm not winning anymore
look at this
God damn it that car's on fire that
car is straight up on
fire
and like the handling is so good like
you can really feel you lose grip that
guy totally smashed that concrete wall
look at this all these
tires remember when games had trouble
like animating one tire or like doing
the physics for it look at this guy look
at this guy he thinks he's a good racer
no you're not you son of a
oh I'm going to reset my
car
oh the front of my car is really messed
up I can't really turn to the left very
well anymore Let Go thing there's only
two laps left oh
oh it's so close there was a car
hidden in that tire
wall like I can't remember the last time
I was in like what what position I inan
like 16th or something and had that much
fun in a in a in a car game
bur go away oh you piece
of AI is really good as well like
they're not they're not super dumb but
they they do make stupid mistakes and
they do get like overly aggressive with
you if you're like racing for position
position they'll kind of throw
themselves into
you I love this area here because if you
get nudged by anyone there you're
hitting one of those piles of dirt and
then you're just going
Sky getting skyrocketed I'm actually in
15 I guy had like two pretty bad crashes
on that and I'm still halfway into the
pack oh oh no
no I'm still
competitive that dude just flew off the
edge there oh
turn all right final left I'm in
ninth a bunch of them crashed all right
if I finish in the top 10 I'll be pretty
happy drift I can't drift cuz my back
tires are my front tires are kind of
they won't they won't turn hard
enough
don't know if the uh if it's got some
spin tires physics happening here with
the with the dirt on the ground I
don't thinking not
but and if they added that as well that'
just be
ridiculous oh
God still in ninth looking good for a
top 10
position
I just so much of this game is actually
finishing with the car still
intact here we go here we go
stop almost there cross the finish line
in ninth oh oh he's lost oh
sick recovery look at all those
cars just
beached the graveyard of tires here
right
fourth what the hell happened
there
replay all right what I want to see more
than anything else is the dudes who hit
into the tire wall over here it was the
funniest thing I've seen slow it down to
not the whole way let's
go
1.5 all right5 speed
I put this guy into a tire barrier
pretty good
here but it was the next area where all
the madness
happened that's that's me pushing the
dude
over like how cool is
that look at this look at these
guys
went right through
it I think somebody launched
here I think somebody went
wide oh yeah that guy oh they all they
all
did somebody hit that tire
wall sure somebody hit
this
I guess the main one I'm wondering about
is there was a big crash right near the
end where beached all those cars like I
don't know how I got from 15th to 9th
and I sure as hell don't know how I got
from 9th to Fourth on the last on the
last lap so let's uh let's speed this up
a bit
coming here they are here they're
coming all right I I may be wrong but I
feel like somebody somebody went into
this wall over
here they're doing
okay all right that guy ate it that's
the guy who who everything up for
everyone because then everyone just went
look at
this
oh yeah there you go oh
yeah there's just not enough space there
for two of
the you have the AI all right let's
speed it up
again you need like four speed that's
pretty
good see wait for the cars to come over
the hill over here here right here we
go here we
go oh yeah that guy ate
it they all
did yep see you a that guy up the top
just went straight
in it was like the worst place for all
of them to be fighting for position on
like Corner oh so that's what it was so
this guy here is is beached so they're
all driving around him to try and make
the corner and they're all they're all
eating it when they come here that's
great so that was lap two but on lap
three on lap three oh God damn it on lap
three I feel like a bunch more of them
crashed
I'm pretty sure you guys are finally
this entertaining as well right because
like I've never spent this much time in
a replay thing before look at this stup
look at this nonsense that guy flipped
upside down before he even got to the
corner this is how I ended up getting
fourth see
you oh he saved it did he look it's just
that car is parked there and they're all
dodging it oh they're actually like
dancing off of it or something there's
like something here that's
some Physics
trickery oh
man this game is the best this game is
the absolute
best I'm going to try a different level
I can play this game all
day maybe I will I'm going to have this
little little European hot hatch and go
race
in
mud pit oh that's a derby all right or a
Darby depending on where you're
from got that
tire I still haven't seen that film
about the tire what's called rubber the
one about the tire that's
haunted
right I think we all know how this ends
I love how they've just playing this
like really somber piano
music it let's go I feel like I
should have brought a bigger car but
okay yeah oh my
dick in previous games the key was to
reverse into people and save your
engine that's what I will continue to
try and
do I think he get points for finishing
cars in
this kind of
remember really I've never tried to win
any of these I just want to have fun
crashing into people this thing is
really I like this car a
lot pretty
spicy yeah that guy's reversing too he
knows what's
up all right come here
here some of a
yeah my little my little crappy
car is not is ill equipped to deal with
these
ah this guy's reversing look what you
think you're doing
boy eat
that these tires
bam
look at that thing look at that
car picked that thing up look at this
yoke look how compressed the oh my God
my car is not looking too hot
either I have zero takedowns so far
apparently if I get one I'll be happy at
this
right
oh all right you got at this stage now
you want to look for the weaklings you
got to go for the got to go for the the
weak in Weak ones in the pack like this
thing look at that
yoke yeah oh wait critical damage that's
not good
uh-oh uh-oh I'm stuck I'm
stuck I can't reverse too
good there we go all right I'm out of
here see
you think you win based on points and
not on
Surviving
yeah eat it
take Downs still zero all
right
yeah I think I missed
him a this car ain't looking too good
look at the front
wheels oh
Jesus
bam yeah I put you in the
wall all right I think that could
probably go on for quite a while so I'm
just going to get out of
that let's do a race
baby I want to race on dirt maybe Let's
Race on dirt see what
happens definitely bringing that car
there that's a nippy thing it nice and
spry and
fast
H
tarmac all right let's see what tac's
about I don't think I've actually done
tarmac
yet I imagine there are quite a lot of
tires
around I hope you're not getting tired
of watching me play this
game
get
TI
tired
all cars to the start Finish
Line we
go yeah look how fast this thing is
I'll drive on the grass
woo SC your tarmac ah look at that guy
bet he's real pissed off I hit him look
he still can't control his car into the
wall baby into the wall oh Jesus there's
like a
bridge I wonder if he can take down that
bridge
that would suck for everyone involved
hey look at that
bridge look this is the most violent ass
driving game ever like I'm not saying
something cuz the the previous the flat
out games if you crashed into a tree
like your dude would actually fly out of
the front of the car and
scream all these
tires I'm just going to cut across here
if you guys don't
mind oh oh the sign just ate it look at
this
nonsense oh that guy's in it yo look at
that wall look at that
wall oh could you imagine being a
spectator at this race is just
rubber flying
everywhere get out Tire stuck under my
stupid
car
oh oh God
19 to 24 that's not good oh look it's
the last hey look at that
oh all right
boy there's like one column holding up
that bridge on that
side
whoa there's something really good about
watching a guy who who's got like his
his his front of his car is so messed up
that he can't turn either left or right
and he's just struggling so hard to do
it and then like pitifully just slowly
drives in straight into a concrete
wall eat
it it's so satisfying crashing in other
cars like this
guy eat
it
H
oh just cut across these fields if you
don't guys don't mind oh look all of the
oh Jesus Wa that was that was pretty
incred incredible it was like a VAR kick
flip uh yeah you just bring me you bring
me over the line will
you sick
recovery the battle for 17th place is
hotting
off my car is almost dead so I
better oh
Jee no look at that for
handling
ah I didn't finish I didn't cross the
line I hit the stupid
wall
finish
yeah oh I'll have a replay of that
please
sir
absolutely all
right feel like there's only one place
we can watch this one
from
the peaceful
Forest you can barely hear
them somewhere in the
distance
that guy just gets pile drived through
all of
them on to the next
one oh so
quiet
all these guys are fine it's this dude
in the background he's like nope I think
that's the guy I put into the wall yeah
there's my little
dude and then I think I ate a tree or
something
Yep this game is so
ridiculous all right one more I just
want to look at the I want to look at
what happened over here and then we
can I'll do another race one more one
more race maybe look at this I think it
was here where it all just went
absolutely catastrophically bad for
everyone all right let's do this in full
speed those guys are fine great
y nope oh oh God oh God damn
it I don't even think I made it over
here yet have
I look at this guy the little C that
could let's see how he
did I'm pretty sure I got knocked down
first time we went around maybe the data
isn't 100%
correct sometimes it's fun just to watch
one dude and see how he did look at this
guy yeah nailed it nice work
dude he's like I got to catch up with
them I got to catch up with them I got
to I got to make my mom
proud what the
hell you just ate
it yeah just back out there you
go
I got to see how he does I'm pulling for
this guy now I'm his fan I'm his biggest
fan his only's fan he almost hit that
concrete block this guy's this guy's
candling is just really something
else you can do it just miss all the
blocks
oh you can do
it we got a big right turn coming up be
careful
boy all right they're catching up with
you mate you want going to hurry
up you got
it just Corner cutting all over the
place a he got
overtaken had had de pressing for him
and all of his
fans I guess the most important thing
now is that he just doesn't hit that
same light post again that would be
really
embarrassing
what I don't believe
it number 26 outd
by you're is bad mate you're is
bad if he hits it the third time around
I swear to
God he's leading the pack here
it's almost as I wonder if they're on
like tracks at this stage because that's
just ridiculous you can do
it just took out that yellow car
dude oh I guess the race finished he
never made it
home that is next car game available
on
Steam it's not
cheap but it is you know it's a it's a
full game when this game comes out it'll
probably cost a lot more than it is on
Early Access uh let's check it out I
think it's $29.99 let me just double
check let's go to the steam
Store free to play documentary R
valve that documentary is
also free to
play next car
game $29.99
you get access to the physics game thing
I showed you and
also
uh also the straight up beta and they've
been doing a great job of of adding to
it and sticking some sticking some cool
things in
there that's fun it's got physics all
that nonsense it's pretty
good Brad all right thank you very much
for hanging out today random encounter
if you have any suggestions as ever Dan
D on Twitter thanks everyone in the
production Booth behind for uh watching
me play with a replay editor for 40
minutes look at this how many points you
going to
get yes seven points oh you get
ground up at the end that's pretty
good and again that's pretty good Next
Car Game available now on star.com
bugbear entertainment uh I will see you
guys next next week have
videos